[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the coverage of uh iem
and gm norm congress
um
i am grand master elian nishnik and i'll
be uh i'll be your host your host for
today
so um
i was told that there already has been a
couple of decisive results but before um
before we jump into the action let me uh
remind you all what is
an iem and gm norm congress event so an
enorm event is an event where a player
can
play up titled players and by beating
them and by scoring well against those
title players
one can
win a norm of their own
just remind you guys that their the
requirement for an international master
or a gm or a grand master title is three
international master or group master
norms respectively so by participating
in these i am norm events one is you
know giving themselves a chance to to
shoot to uh to an international master
or master title
and here we have
we have a more more detailed explanation
about about what is required and how the
norms are awarded and what is you know
the uh the average rating needed
to uh to win
a norm
and also actually a very important very
important point to make is that there
needs to be at least four different
nationalities for for the norm event to
uh to be uh
official
okay so um
i guess we are
skipping through uh
through the uh or are we skipping
through the standings
i guess we can probably uh uh
cover what the schedule is right so the
schedule okay here here are the
standings already had a little bit of
delays there so the standing for the for
the gm norm event vladimir belos is kind
of killing it he uh he is
he's one point ahead um
of of places
two to four with with a score of four
and a half out of six um then trailing
by a point and a half is christopher
repka with three out of six and then we
have ivan shitko uh josiah steermann
with two points kostya kabuski was one
and a half victor matvision was one and
even park was half a point out of six
possible uh now moving on to the uh the
i am norm event
standings
here they are we have aaron grobinski
leading with the same score four and a
half of six so score of plus three then
um
with four points uh trailing are
matthias marek and joshua postooma then
we have jennifer you with three out of
six uh on the sole fourth place then we
have ezra chambers who's a good friend
of mine and my former teammate
i was two and a half out of six uh
following is begum tajiri genova with
two points and places from seven to nine
are shared between three players gabriel
antonov
gabriel
and um and the last place is pedro
rodriguez was half a point out of six
out of five
i apologize out of five yeah a little
bit of a of a typo on my parts there
um
speaking of the schedule right so this
event uh has um two games a day except
for games
in round eight and nine those games are
single games beginning at 11 o'clock
uh in the morning on monday may 23rd and
tuesday may 24th respectively
so we are slowly approaching
the end of the event we have two more
approaches three more days after today
and the event will be the events will be
concluded
so um
once again please uh just to make sure
you guys stay in tune please make sure
to follow up the uh youtube twitch uh
youtube you know saintlicious clubs
youtube and twitch social media and um
use hashtag norm congress to share your
thoughts and uh
feelings about these events
now
price funds apparently these events
feature quite substantial
but substantial price fund
let's see if we can get price funds
up on our screen
there they are so the grandmaster
section features 10 prizes so everyone
playing is going to get a prize
first prize being two thousand dollars
1500 for for second place
one thousand dollars for third place and
then we have um
800 for fourth place seven hundred for
fifths
six hundred four places through six till
eight oh sorry three six oh wait
actually just 600 up until the last
place
and then for i am event
i suppose the price is going to be a
little smaller yeah because
the first price is 400 then we have a
thousand dollars 700 600 500 and then
closing in with 400 for places from 6th
to 10th
okay
so i guess now as we got
this info autos away let's jump into
the games shall we
11 a.m early morning
yeah 11 a.m is uh is a tough uh tough
run time for chess players
um i'm i'm i'm used to uh i i myself am
not a morning person so rounds begin
early
um you know the earlier the round begins
the more difficult it is for me to uh to
perform
oh yes let's before we jump into the
game so let's take a quick look at the
pairings who is playing whom we have uh
um in the in the gm section we um
we have we already had quite a few
results jesus human uh
uh beasted joshua castillo the current
leader of the event for other bellows
drew the gopari balaji then we have
david brosky against ivan shitko the
game is still ongoing
uh and so is chris rapka versus kostya
kabutsuki's game and then and finishing
as evan park versus mr mattvision who
also drew
now on to the iem pairings
we have joshua postuma versus edward
chambers the game is still ongoing in
fact the only result of of today's round
for the iem section is gabriella and
antoine versus pedro rodriguez uh these
two drew each other and then we have
every other game is the still lasting
it's begum taher genova versus julian
proleko alice lee versus aaron grobinski
and jennifer you versus matthias marek
so a lot a lot of games to still look at
we have four games in the iem section
and uh and i believe two games in in the
gm section still ongoing
i believe that um we may actually have
we may actually see a result
um here in this good ski the last move
played was rook to h8 which is an
amazing
amazing tactic um distraction of the
rook now obviously if black takes but
captures the rook they actually have no
no other option but to do so white will
play knight c8 intercepting the
the rook and
promotion is
incoming so i believe i tend to believe
that the game was
the game officially ended here because
as as notation shows black's next move
was king e4 which is an illegal move
because it it places the king under a
knight's attack so
in if this is the case it likely means
that that the game was concluded and the
you know the two kings were placed in
the middle of the board white king being
on a white square so that's why we see a
movie king e4 being made or just because
the kings were had to be put there to
indicate the results so i believe white
won this game even though it's not yet
updated
um but now we have this game which is
also a very very exciting rook and game
i uh um this is a game again this is a
game broski versus shitko and um
we have a very unusual rook rook rook
and game where white is missing a pawn
but they um
they have two two past pawns right so
they also what what is also notable is
that the rook is
holding a perfect position right so in
rook and games uh whichever side hasn't
has a past pawn
uh
the best positioning for your rook when
when you do have a passport and a rook
end game is right behind it right so in
this case
white rook is right behind
white's past pawn on h6 meaning that the
the black rook is stuck having to to
block the pawn otherwise it's going to
promote right so the black rook cannot
escape
if if the pawn on h6 was white was
white's only past pawn then there will
be no issues right because well
as as things stand right now without
help of white's king white cannot really
promote this guy right so
white's plan
without this passport on his three would
likely be something like this which is
very easily stoppable
right so what goes king d3
all black has to do is to put the king
on the fifth string
in fact black can even follow up by
bringing the king in closer to the h6
pawn and just capturing it with the rook
that would be uh that would be a pretty
uh simple
game for black and i'm pretty sure they
would win due to their
major
material advantage but obviously this is
not the case why it still has
why is this blue it's not okay there you
go i figured this out all right there we
go
drawing is is a scale that i would like
to master one day
i wouldn't call myself a great artist as
you guys can tell and drawing arrows on
the board is difficult
obviously here white has another pass
pawn which plays into white's hands
quite a bit right so now if black tries
for the same plan of bringing the king
closer to the white pawn on h6 they're
gonna fail
um
so i believe the king d6 move was played
and now um
i would say white should probably try to
charge
the a pawn up in fact actually if you
guys notice in this case in this
position black could have already played
kf6 but once again this plan would fail
because
because of white's other past pawn right
now captures obviously
the black king is going to fail to to
catch
the passer on a6 which is going to
promote to a queen
and this is why actually black made a
very very sound decision by deciding to
keep the rook as a blocking piece for
this pawn and use the king to catch up
to the past a5 pawn i strongly believe
that black is likely is very likely to
win this game
um
not just because of the fact that
they're up upon but also because of the
fact that the only way for white to make
progress in in this position is to use
the king right right now without the
help of white's king neither one of
these two pawns can promote
so i would suppose the king has to do
something or try try to has to try to do
something so one of the more obviously
one of the more obvious plans i see is
to once again
start rushing the king towards the spawn
h6
but now actually what's going to happen
is that even if black has to give up the
rook for the pawn right
oftentimes you will see rook and games
like these where black gives up a rook
for the pawn but you know
these guys
along alongside the black king are
unstoppable right so at this point black
and just started pushing the pawns and
you know
there is no stopping them the rook
itself cannot handle all these pawns in
fact the rook itself cannot even handle
a single pawn with the help of the king
all right so this
is definitely uh an exciting end game to
to look forward to
i
once again my intuitional understanding
is that black is gonna win this game
because of simply because of this fact
that their you know their their play is
very simpler than whites white needs to
come up with something unusual to to
hold or something unusual to make to
make to create some issues for black
because if if white follows through with
my ideas i would just lose so there's
got to be something else so this is the
last game of
this is this is the last game of the gm
of a grand master section now let's move
oops nope that's not it let's move back
on to the uh the im section and here we
have
we have
the games that are still
suffering from um
from issues with gt boards i believe
because some of these games are paused
for example the
okay never mind never mind all we had to
do was just refresh a page and now
they're all updated it's all good now we
can go back
to uh
to the games themselves
there we go okay perfect
yet another rook and game here
which sees
why it's clearly being in a driver's
seat right so white and this working
game white has
excuse me
oh okay so i'm being told that uh
jennifer you just
made a critical blunder
with rook e3 blundering a pen
bishop h6 more rook in games yeah i'm
i'm honestly very excited about rook and
games because you know rook and games is
something that
that's very very difficult to master but
it's extremely rewarding once you do
and obviously you know needless to say
rook and games are
among the most frequently occurring end
games in the game of chess so knowing
knowing them is definitely
gonna gonna prove useful and here we see
actually white is about to lose by force
because blackheads just captures the
rook i suppose
the idea is that white maybe can utilize
the fact that this pawn is pinned
but now here we have a very nice trick
right so the rook is the piece spinning
the pawn
so what black can do is
just remove the pinning piece right just
capture the rook
capture the queen
and voila
black has upper piece
in fact upper rook it's not just the
pieces the whole rook
so i guess this is what we're going to
see there is really not
not that many options for actually i
guess black can can also include
h4 if they really want to but they
absolutely don't have to
i'm not sure what's going on here we
this happened yeah okay so why did
resign i suppose um
yeah queen of four was played maybe it
was
it was a mouse slip quote unquote and
white wanted to take on a fire but
realize that that it's losing and just
surrendered without finishing their move
very unfortunate um end of the game for
for jennifer it seems based on the
notation it seems that white wasn't
doing
that well throughout the game
anyway
actually let me let me quickly go over
the entire game because it seems that
white
has been up in exchange
uh for a very long time but but still
white's position wasn't great so it's
got to be some kind of some kind of
positional sacrifice used by uh by uh
matthias um
a3 is is a move that's kind of hated by
the engine here
um
it feels it feels wrong because white is
postponing the development so much you
see in all these all these night moves
white has spent
a lot of time moving their knights
around so this knight went all the way
to b3 this knight went to a4 that's a
lot of moves to make with the same piece
in the opening right making your
development phase very inefficient and
as black just didn't do anything special
they just developed
and as we as we see some comments were
made by talia here uh where she points
out that the knight can be transported
to b6
um but here yeah matthias decided to to
play up against the white key
immediately by opening up the center
and i guess this is where yeah this is
where we see an exchange sacrifice which
is a sound sacrifice just because white
is so behind in development and the king
is so
so bad okay yeah why does manage to
solve their development issues but it
costs um
it costs them some stuff
i suppose yeah actually if it feels like
black pieces are just holding dominating
positions especially the black knights
taking away so many important squares
from white pieces and it seems that
white can barely move
anything at all
so you see the white divide is forced to
make moves such as kh1
and yeah and here comes the first
blunder
so this is basically this basically was
this basically happened by force and
here room d8
um
queen f2 was was a blunder where
jennifer
missed e4 and i guess the game was
basically over after it
also e4 is not very
why is e4 not good
is there anything white can do now after
e4
oh okay so over here okay i see so over
here white should have gone okay this is
not simple at all so over here watch
white hat only move which is rook e to
e2
followed by bishop d3 and rook e3
using the fact that now the bishop is
pinned once again
quite a quite a difficult uh
tactic to see and even to understand
that this this makes a difference
obviously rookies it's it's either rook
e1 or rookie two at this point right
because ricky's three runs into bishop
h6 so i guess jennifer was running
really long time as we see she was
playing on increments and and blunders
uh you know
don't
don't wait
do remember i i cannot i cannot stress
it enough the time management is one of
the most important parts of the chess
game especially
when you play classical
because
in classical chess it may seem that you
will never flag because you always have
either a delay or an increment but it's
very deceiving
people do flag
all right let's move on and
check this game between aaron grobinski
and alice lee we have um
we have a closed
kings in the king king's indian like
structure
where obviously black i would say black
is the one trying to make stuff happen
why you may wonder well because the one
of the main reasons for why i think
black is in the driver's seat here is
because
the difference between these two pieces
right so when we look at black's light
squared bishop and white's y squared
bishop b that we can clearly see that
white's widespread bishop can only be a
defending piece well black's light
squared bishop
is applying pressure against the h3 pawn
that's probably the only thing it's
doing right now the phone and a4 cannot
really be won
um
it may seem actually it seems that
maybe
white's position is solid enough to hold
for a draw but you see actually aaron
finds a very nice manure bringing the
net over to g3 the other night at the
same time there's nothing see it it's
not being used in any way right now this
knight is about to
travel to f4 and once once those two
knights
you know uh get into their positions on
g3 and f4 respectively
then we um
we may see something happen but actually
aaron does not go for an e786 which is
rather surprising
he might have a different plan on his
mind and i think i i understand what
he's trying to do so instead of
doing that he is he's actually going to
be it's likely it's likely that aaron is
going to go for a positional sacrifice
on f3 so to breach voice position here
black
it is very likely that black
putting their knights nicely on f4 and
g3 would not be enough to make progress
so here what aaron is trying to go for
is a simple rocket f8 and just take on
f3
opening up a file for his rook
let's see if it works out for aaron and
while alice is thinking by the way alice
is really long time here with one minute
on her clock while aaron has 14 it
definitely will play
a big role
if not now than later on so queen e3 i
suppose yes ellis is trying to over
protect the opponent of three but for
now let's switch to um
to her genre versus uh
prolaco and here we have a draw
it is um
a theoretical draw king and pawn versus
king
still made this
shortly to follow
okay
so i guess it it only makes it so that
we have these two games here so um
joshua bostoma versus ezra chambers
a rook in game yet another one
i would definitely take white because
white does have a pawn
black blue the opponent game and and
julian proviker's game
actually let's take a look
oh my really
this pawning game is supposed to be
winning right because
yeah because yeah because it's two
versus one and there's eventually going
to be
so at this point there must be there
must be some kind of win by force here
up that's what i would expect so for
example
uh-huh i see so i think yes the king i
would say that the decision black's
decision to bring the king over to h4
was was uh was the wrong one i would say
the king has to go to e4 here
so i would i would say that this is an
easy win and now obviously not never
take on f3 because that's basically
transposed into the same position as in
the game but go g3 and here we have
here we have a very very simple and
straightforward end game where
blockchain just goes around
and takes
the only defender
so i'm i'm getting a confirmation that
the game did indeed end in a draw here
and it's very unfortunate for julian he
also had a lot of time on his clock so a
very unfortunate way to to oh my god
here here comes
here comes the blunder here comes the uh
the critical
point of the game where julian blunder
this this very nice maneuver f3
forcing black to
yeah taking on s3 would not have changed
anything as now it's it's one the king
has to move away and
and we have a we have a troll
very unfortunate blunder but it happens
it happens to the best of us
let's see uh alice
alice's game did not really see the wind
it was it was easy yeah but yeah it
happens yeah
julian has just waved at me saying that
it's uh it was a very simple task and he
failed it but it happens once again
chess is a sport
we just have to you know
stay strong and move on that's all we
can do
and i hope it helped julian's
uh remaining games who
will see more luck than this one uh
we have we have this position of
of ezra versus joshua here
it seems that yeah it seems black is
winning one of their one of their
missing pawns back but obviously it's
still
i would say it's still a lost end game
so this might be
i'm trying to think of a plan of a
winning plan here for white and i feel
like this might be an exception so
remember how i told you guys that the
rook is
praised best behind the pawn
i think this this position might just be
one of those exceptions where the pawn
would actually oh sorry the rook would
actually be better off
on the side
of the pawn
so rook e3 was indeed played and let's
see i'm not sure if
wyatt can make
progress here so i'm expecting black to
go h5 now
trading
trading one pawn pair
if if white allows black to take in g4 i
think the game is just going to be a
draw immediately because
because black will
get directed for although this is still
unclear i would i wouldn't say this is
so clear because now white has rook f3
no this is no this is actually lost
right this is actually losing because
obviously if black black takes there is
nothing to be to be said here white
comes picks up the pawn and then
promotes promotes their jeep pawn very
easily right so actually um actually
black cannot be doing this but i cannot
be taking an f3 cannot be going into a
pawn end game so instead i suppose they
would try to avoid the trade but now we
will have an end game like this
where once again the king if the king if
this king was somewhere on g8 or on g7
this would be a theoretical draw where
black
can uh can build a philidors uh a
philadelphia's fortress right the
philadelphia defense's position oh sorry
if not for the defense i feel there's
position i feel their defense i have uh
yeah one of my main weaknesses is
philadelphia defense i don't know how to
deal with it
don't tell anyone uh-huh yeah so
in this case however it is not gonna
happen as the king is a bit too far off
and white will have no issues just
moving the king away and promoting with
help of the rook
so
not so simple once again rook and games
are not easy and uh
you know
the only thing i can i can i can say
here is that
anything can still happen i'm still
taking white because once again white is
in the driver's seat it's it's difficult
for black to defend this they're about
to run out of time
you know it's rook and games are
a precision based and games where a
single misstep can cost you a game
and um
you know let's see let's see what
happens let's see how how black defends
this let's see how how they attempt to
survive here in the meantime
let's quickly switch to
to um
alice's game against aaron and here we
see that aaron is still
trying his best to build
or to not to build but to break
we have some
tiny technical issues here okay i'm back
um yeah so
aaron is still trying to break through
alice's fortress on the king side here i
don't really see a way alice has
actually
spotted a very nice
maneuver to bring that over to g1 but
this is this might be aaron's chance
this if anything this is probably
aaron's chance to to get the sacrifice
that he wanted so here this
trade
leads to black having to sacrifice their
the exchange right so
black would sacrifice the exchange and
then they would place the knight on a
four so you see now
now black's winning plan here is also i
would say it's a it is a plan it is a
very simple plan which is to play g4
and create a passer on the h file this
would be
black's
quote-unquote winning plan which but i'm
not sure if it's winning or not
once
again okay so we have we have another
result
uh
okay so david bro david brought david
brosky versus even [ __ ] the game did end
in the draw here apparently
aha so apparently there is a fortress
that white can build here to prevent the
black from making progress as well so
here we here we see this this fortress
where
black cannot do anything and neither can
white
both sides are forced to repeat moves
and if any if any pawn moves happen if
black does decide to go for pawn breaks
through then they may actually regret it
eventually so that's why
we did not see
even
giving it a shot because it's kind of
you know it is pretty uh uh pretty scary
if you're raw if you push the pawn
and you're wrong you may even lose the
game that you will you would never ever
lose otherwise so
well thought to both players we still
have
this no we don't have any more games
this was the last game of the iem
international master norm section
we can
close this tab and for give our full
attention to
the gm section and it seems that
it seems that aaron did not capture the
pawn f3 but instead decided to go for
the knight g3 move
knight g1 and once again we may see we
may actually see white holding
because i honestly do not see
this happen i honestly do not see how
at this stage of the game how black will
ever make progress right white has a
perfect
defensive setup
there is nothing to be attacked in
white's position there's there's nothing
to be up there's not no peace in white's
position that can be applied that that
can be
that black can apply more pressure on
both of these pawns are are defended
perfectly we have
three defenders for each of these pawns
and it's
very very difficult to find
any plant here full bucket i will even
cheat a little bit and use help of the
engine the engine owner obviously
believes that bragas black is trying to
win showing a a
minus 1.4 advantage for black but
doesn't give anything definite
no definite plan
and i feel like this game is very likely
to to end in a draw because at this
point all white has to do is just move
back and forth
uh to hear general versus prologue did
okay wait obviously we did finish in the
draw because i saw julian so case this
was a draw now this game is
one of the final games of the event
where ezra is
thinking hard about his next move trying
to not be wrong trying to find the best
way possible to
get to have to give himself the most
chances to survive
so h5 once again my my attempt to play
h5 might have been
might have been just straight up wrong
well because of because of what happens
right so we've looked at this
we've looked at this variation where
white
blocks blocks the black rook and just
wins
let's see what else what else is there
so ke4 is is about to happen
regardless of what black does right so
king is coming to e4
no matter what so maybe
maybe black needs to employ
a different strategy so maybe black
needs to do this
to try and keep the white king off
the fifth rank because essentially
white's plan is very simple white simply
wants to get go here and pick up the
pawn on h6 once the king reaches g6 i'm
pretty sure there is no way
for black to not lose the h6 pawn so
here i would i would strongly i would
yeah not strongly but i would definitely
look into this
as a
as a defensive option
i honestly believe it's not enough
because
the reason for
this endgame
likely been lost
what's happening we have an ad break
okay there we go
okay yeah i i looked out i looked up to
the screen and then i see
i see mauricio talking and i'm like oh
wait is it is this an outbreak i'm last
time i checked he wasn't here
unless i somehow missed him on the chair
right next to me
here
i think this is still a lost end
game because
the reason for why i'm saying this is
because even if this trade happens right
even if it's this is probably one of the
best case scenarios for for black i
would assume this this trade
pawn on a6 for pawn on h6
white is up a pawn
but
what is not just upper pawn white is for
opponent and the black king is so far
away from this side right so if black
king could magically trans you know
teleport to g7 right now i'm pretty sure
would have a draw in our hands
but because the king is so far away from
the king's side
i would say all white has to do is well
first of all white can just immediately
win by doing this and then
black can never accept the the rook
trade because then it's a pawn on game
which is winning for white since i would
have to end up losing the opponent g5
and then we have a rook and two pawns
versus rook which is a very easy win for
the side with two pawns
so i honestly believe that this end game
is just
straight up straight up lost
so we have
we have h5 happening
and then h4 happened okay so so ezra
correctly identified that take you on g4
would be
would be likely losing so we have h4
king f5 and now rook g2 happened but
once again this is probably just a
just uh
actually no it's not that simple no it
should be pretty simple yes i think it's
pretty simple to when white needs to
just take on g5
player four and once again place the
rook behind the pawn stance this this
technique stands
for the defending side as well the rook
is is better placed behind the passport
obviously black has to follow by
capturing here and now it's going to be
a race which i believe white is going to
win wait maybe even just f7 right just
f7
king g6
and
maybe even just capture an h2
distracting the rook now
it would be it would be a very
interesting end game if y did not have a
pawn on g4 this pawn was gone if we
would have a queen versus rook end game
which which is winning in in theory but
in practice may pose some problems
honestly
to be completely honest with you guys
i've i've trained
uh i've trained
and to win this game by by playing
against the um against the strongest
stock fish there is and i don't think
i've ever managed to beat stockfish in a
queen versus rook end game
the defensive capabilities of the of the
side of the rook are
really impressive but obviously for a
human being it would be
you know much more difficult than it is
for for the machine but still it would
be interesting to see this this kind of
end game happen in the
game
all right let's switch back to
alice's game we have wherever see no no
progress
as of right now and honestly
um
i i'm not sure what what
what is what is going to happen so
aaron decided to bring the bishop over
to h5
and and it doesn't seem to be doing much
right now so um if he i'm pretty sure
that if black wants to try and win these
games they do have to
eventually sacrifice on f3 so
somehow black needs to make
tripling possible right now i'm not sure
if it's possible here because
because the g5 pawn is hanging right so
if queen goes to f7
black is going to lose the pawn on g5
but
you know
actually maybe maybe this would be a
this this might be a uh
a very nice trap because here black has
rook f4 and and the queen may not even
be able to come come back right now the
queen is trapped in g5 black's next move
is rogue g8
and the queen the white queen will keep
getting
chased around the board
may or may not black may or may not
catch it
so now g8 happened
not entirely sure what the plan of
knight g8 is
maybe
um where is the knight gonna go
h6 f7 but then where
where next yeah
not quite sure so yeah i'm failing to
see a winning pattern here at the
position definitely looks very nice for
black but i feel like aaron might have
might have missed or maybe maybe not
miss but i think he just deliberately
did not want to
to go for this position where he has to
sacrifice an exchange and sometimes
in chess
um the best the best way is not
not
the no it's it's it's um
what i'm trying to say here is that in
chess the correct pass is oftentimes
more confusing and harder to explain
than
than a more straightforward approach so
in this case you don't know what's going
to happen when you sacrifice
i i can tell you for sure that black is
never going to be in danger because if
black doesn't want to try to win this
position right
they can just keep the net in a four
and
there's nothing right can do right
there's nothing that can do why does not
have open files okay so we have we have
a result um joshua apostoma did
when uh did beat uh ezra chambers
and um
and the computer was was
computer actually confirms my suspicion
that this position is just
straight up lost for
for
for black
actually joshua joshua fonda
and joshua found a very nice maneuver vs
king to approach the h2 pawn and just
eat it
and that was it
so we have this game ending with white's
victory and now it's just this game of
ellis lee between
against aaron grobinski
once again hard to say something about
black's attempt here
very very tough position to break
through and white does not need to at
this point white just doesn't even need
to spend any time whatsoever because you
know oftentimes when you have a
when you have a
you know unclear position with one side
having a major
uh time advantage then
by just keeping the position unclear for
as long as possible the side with extra
time can apply maximum pressure
but here
the position is not that unclear all
white has to do is just sit and wait and
do nothing so
the uh the time the time difference
between the players is not as important
anymore and therefore
soon enough aaron will find himself in
in the same spot where he
he will be in time pressure and he will
you know he will have to make a decision
where whether he wants to commit
and make stuff happen
while being in the same time time
pressure situation or whether he just
wants to um
or whether he just wants to take it easy
and and go for a uh
a more safe option of making a draw
i'm using the engine says that the dgt
white wins position is like minus 50.
what do i mean -50 is the dgt white wins
is not even a legal position
it's two kings next to each other no
hello ben
welcome
evaluation of illegal position oh okay
it's just nonsense okay gotcha i thought
okay
i said there's some kind of confusion
but the engine actually evaluates the
illegal position well all right
it just gives a random eval nice
that's that's got to be a bug right
it's got to be a box that stockfish
still evaluates
ah actually i'm gonna try it i'm gonna
try it at home like set up an illegal
position and use stockfish and see what
it says
i've never done that but that sounds
like fun
all right so we have a bunch of waiting
moves being made by both sides in fact
it's funny but sometimes
or not in sometimes but it may so
happens that we will see a 50 move rule
can you guys imagine the 50 move rule
for those of you who don't know is is uh
is
basically a rule that that prevents
games from being played forever so if
there is no progress made and by
progress we imply any pawn moves or any
captures if there are no no pawn moves
or no captures
for 50 moves or more
one of the sides can legally claim a
draw
so in this case no pawn moves no pawn
moves will likely occur right because
well
the only pawn moves would be pawn moves
that that give up a pawn so i'm pretty
sure both sides would not consider those
and no it's likely that no captures will
happen as well because well
only black can capture stuff here and
all of white's pawns all of white's weak
pawns are well guarded so
it's funny but starting from 57
if you start calling for move 57 because
that's where white played b3 which is
the very last pawn move being made now
starting from 58 we can count the count
for the 50 move rule meaning that by
move 108
if players reach move 108
the game can be declared draw okay so in
here
aaron did manage to
aaron did manage to actually to um to
create a um
to triple up on the on the f5 i'm not
sure i'm not exactly sure what it does
for him right so i think black's next
move is going to be queen of fate or
something
once again i'm not entirely sure what
black's next steps are so obviously
black does not want to capture an g4
because then after h takes g4
uh the position becomes even more locked
down
although even there like let's be fair
even in that in that position so if in
case black does decide to take here
[Applause]
over here black can decide to take to
capture on g4
obviously white has to take with an h
pawn if y takes with a
with a f pawn they lose upon e4 and game
shortly after
so they have to capture with an h pawn
and now well the position has become
even more locked down but obviously
black still has
ways to break through
the question is whether aaron is
committed enough
to attempt this because once again if
you if you sacrifice a piece and then
it appears that you are wrong with your
assessment of the position you're
running a risk to lose and
and especially when you have as little
time as
you know nine or eight minutes on your
clock it becomes ever more
ever more tricky to evaluate
the
sacrifice queen of f8 was indeed played
tripling up on the f-file once again
white just plays a waiting game
continuous playing waiting game and um
let's see if
let's see if there is anything
substantial here for black
the engine
still gives the same evaluation meaning
that
about -1 advantage for black it probably
means that there is actually no way
of no realistic way of making progress
here for black
but once again anything can happen
hmm
aaron is reaching for a move let's see
what he plays
very curious to see what he has in mind
he goes for knight f6
[Music]
well once again i think
objectively best
approach here for what is just sit and
do nothing
and if black wants to sacrifice it
appears that black's attempt to
sacrifice on either e4 or g4 will likely
fail
but yeah we only have
about
35 moves until
either side can legally claim a draw but
i think it's very likely that we will
see
a piece being traded soon right because
the knight is on g4
it's not likely that the knight is going
to leave anytime soon so
it is likely we'll see the capture on g4
and then we'll have to count again but
now i see the knight goes back
to f2
and i feel like we may have to start
playing a waiting game again
the captures on e4 do not work because
then white captures back with the knight
captures on f3 obviously do not work
because white just has way too many
defenders
once again i'm
not sure how to win this
i was let's see actually let's see what
what the engine really thinks about my
idea to sacrifice an exchange so over
here over here quintex f3
it
it actually doesn't mind it i'm
surprised that the engine does not mind
my sacrifice and it actually says that
black has about
point seven of advantage after knight
four
actually goes down now to 0.2 meaning
that it's probably just still a draw
and that black is likely not going to
have enough
to make substantial progress here
but once again in my mind this would be
a a much better try than what's
happening in the game right now
because this right this position it
becomes unclear
this is uh this is material imbalance
and player with white pieces in my mind
is more likely is more prone to making
mistakes or inaccuracies that can be
further exploited
so oops sorry scroll down a bit too far
97 knight g4 happened
you may even see the knight going to um
to a6 and then to b4
which i believe doesn't really make much
of a difference
it's going to be a pretty night on an
outpost but
that's about it
all of the entry points are well guarded
by white pieces
and as you can see aaron did play bishop
g6 knight f2 followed
and yeah white is playing a perfect sit
and wait strategy
[Music]
okay
so i guess while we wait
for something to happen on this board
let's actually uh quickly go over i've
been i was very interested to see
um
to see what what was i interested to see
not not this
i see this is probably why i shouldn't
have closed the
let's go
here and
go back over to
the gm1
i apologize it's going to take me
another minute
okay perfect and i'm here
let's see so the game i was curious
about was
this one
is one wanted to quickly go over this
game between uh josiah steerman and
joshua royce castillo
it seemed like a very cool game and we
have we did we do see bugger indian here
okay we're not boggling sorry queen's
indian
this used to be this used to be a very
very popular line back in my days and by
my days i mean 15
16 17 years back
position moved into into a stonewall
like structure
and black was doing fairly well here in
fact if black decided to take on e4 with
the d pawn which makes a lot of sense
right so taking an e4 with a d point
creates an outpost on d5 for for black
pieces so i think it would actually make
a lot of sense plus it would open up the
d file for for black rooks to occupy
but black chose the other the other
route which is
not bad by any means and you see
typically in stonewall black's main
problem is the light squared bishop but
here the light squared bishop is
actually quite nice on a6
it's doing a lot there
and black correctly identifies the
possibility of of sacrificing exchange
and now
for some reason the engine claims that
this is a double question mark which
it clearly is not
it was some kind of glitch in the system
i believe
and here you hear there's a g6 move
the g6 move which
was left unanswered because here white
missed out an opportunity to
i'm not sure if this is i'm not sure how
good this is because the position is is
so locked up here that i'm not even sure
if white can win it yes white does have
a material advantage here but
but it's it's kind of hard to find to
find a plan here isn't it i guess
white's plan is going to be this
bringing in pieces like so and applying
pressure against the g6 point i guess
that's what white is going to go for
but anyway this this opportunity was
missed by wide and v
be transposed into this into this
position which is very unclear once
again and here actually this this looks
like a direct transposition to to the
position we just we just we've just seen
where white played h4 first it seems
that the h4 move is a key move that
allows y to push the black bishop back
and therefore the only move that holds
everything together for black here is to
play h4 himself
leaving the bishop on g5
and after that we have
yeah we have a little bit of a trouble
for black where
they couldn't they were they were forced
to make passive moves because they
couldn't go for a trade as their dawn
material and eventually
white
found a nice
transposition into this position one
okay
all right let's go back
let us go back to
alice's game and we have
we have
no substantial progress being made so we
still so at this point we only we are
only 20 moves away from
from a 50 move rule right so we began
counting
at move 58 meaning that by move 108
alice will be able to
claim a draw
let's see
so far so good
no blunders on either side
bishop g6
so
i mean black is clearly eyeing the the
this the possibility of sacrificing e4
like it's it's so clear that that's what
black is trying to go for i would say
all white has to do is to just play
bishop c2 here
just you know making sure that the pawn
e4 is well defended
it should be enough now we have you're
looking at one
one two three four five defenders of the
pawn that's
unheard of raid so many defenders for a
single piece but white white can do that
white can afford
spending this much this many resources
just to overprotect the
the only i mean at this point we can
probably argue that the e4 pawn is is a
key piece here because that's that's the
only place where black can sacrifice and
open up the structure
so it's not
it's not unusual for white to to you
know
try as hard as they can and bishop to
was played queen of f8 followed
and actually now there is
is this the position we are looking at
there is knight d3 now isn't there so
white
white can win an exchange by force here
after knight d3
i'm looking at the board right now and i
believe that yes aaron did indeed allow
knight d3 to happen
did it happen
it did not happen i believe king b2
happened in b2 happened
and uh i guess see this is actually
funny because if you think about this
if white goes it might accept the uh the
exchange the the exchange that black is
offering
then the count resets right so at this
point white only needs to waste about 15
more moves
to
be able to claim a draw by the 50 move
rule so at this point actually it's
probably a smarter strategy
on white's part to not accept any
peace trades and any any exchange offers
so very smart i'm actually i'm actually
uh you know
i'm commanding alice for
you know realizing that she probably
just doesn't need to take the rook and a
four at this point
you guys you know objectively speaking
the ancient was saying that oh black
black screwed up right the rook is the
rook is stuck on a four but you just go
pick it up and it's like equal because
well
without an exchange there can be no no
no talk about black making progress
because they're down materials they need
to try and not lose you know being down
material
but that's not true i believe that here
if white went for knight d3
now we would see the knight
placing on an amazing e5 square it's an
amazing outpost and who knows maybe
maybe black would eventually still find
a way to breakthrough with some maybe b
maybe g4 maybe maybe b5 you never know
this knight would be
really really strong on e5
probably not
you know it's it's likely that it
wouldn't be the case but still
no need to force things
we see net f to h5 being played here
once again there is no particular threat
but white can just keep moving back and
forth
bishop d1 happened
my game against kaden
from years ago exchange stack in a
closed in a locked position yeah it's
this is why
this is exactly what they've been
referencing right if you go back over
here i'm not sure if you're not if not
sure if you were here before but black
did have a possibility of sacking an
exchange and in this very moment where
they can capture the pawn
and then here
because there cannot retreat as there is
knight behind it but is forced to suck
the exchange but once again i'm a bigger
fan of buck's position here because it's
it's a close position close pawn
structure and the rooks are not as
strong so i would say that black should
have should have taken this this
opportunity
and practically speaking this is more
this is more this is this is more
difficult for white to defend than what
happened in the game
see we have queen g7 being played and
now it's only a matter of
maybe
no it's it should be
one second so we we are looking at move
number 108 right so wait no actually
it's a substantial amount of moves so
approaches are miscalculated we have we
still have 25 more moves to make
[Music]
25 more moves to make until the official
50 move
50 move rule draw
and once again
there is no challenge for white and this
is why i don't i don't exactly
necessarily like the way aaron played it
because
he was i was let's see will we see at
the time let's say if we go back like by
50 moves or so
so
uh
at some point yeah at some point aaron
was a major major time advantage right
so somewhere here
aaron you see how alice
had only
only about two minutes on her clock but
move 48 and aaron had 17 minutes so in
this position right it's it's a
difficult position to break through once
again it's it was kind of the same but
then once again aaron was given a chance
right aaron was given a chance to you
know to
make stuff happen
because if nothing happens then white
will just move back and forth
until
you know until black
forces something to happen but but can't
and then suddenly
all of a sudden black was given a chance
to make some kind of change to the to
the structure of the position even the
cost of the exchange i would i believe
that it would still be a smarter
practical decision to take on f3
uh we have
queen of six happen and then
let's see is is there any issues with
just continuing the defense yeah
it's still
it is still unchanged
at this point alice just needs to be
watching her clock because well
she is really low on time after all
and once again she is having a chance to
play knight d3 but i'm pretty sure she
will just refuse it and she is
refusing it by playing bishop d1 just
like i predicted
this is a very unique game because
i would say
that in any other game
under different circumstances white
would be happy to
accept material offers right but in this
game you see in this game not accepting
the material
is actually a technique
used to
to draw
faster to draw more efficiently
i think yeah aaron i think at this point
aaron is just whole kind of hoping that
that alice will forget about some kind
of trick like knight takes e4 or bishop
takes e4 but because
incidentally there is
there is almost never
there is no almost never
a tactic involving the sacrifice on e4
unless let's say white moves let's say
white
is not careful and plays what's in it d3
at the wrong moment then black can take
on e4
you know sacrifice a piece open up the f
file and then make stuff happen but
once again
with you know enough caution
once again this is also a a point where
white can play in a d3
but probably will not because there is
no need to once again knight d3 would
probably just
well
if knight d3 if rook f6 we have we have
queen takes g5 and actually why is the
one trying to win at this point because
both are up a pawn but obviously here
but can just leave the rook as is
and uh and you know
if wars comes to wars blood will capture
back of the g pawn and and the the
structure will be will become completely
locked down
without any
hope for either side to improve
can i talk about the the aaron's
decision to play h4 so i guess we're
going back
to move number 45 where the error played
h4 but you see
i feel like i feel like that's that's
that's probably a good point because at
the in this position in this situation
black has
two options or two real choices right
this either h4
or a g4 in terms of pawn breaks right so
i would say there is nothing that
forces black to make the decision right
now
so instead of playing h4 this h4 was
indeed premature like i completely agree
i would say
black would be better off readjusting
their pieces and then making it making a
choice because
h4 is a ver is a critical decision that
that
solidifies the pawn structure and takes
away
other opportunities from black pieces
are there any openings i would recommend
i would recommend
okay first of all
i would i would say there are no easy
openings in chess but i would i would
just suggest picking up something
something more or less let's say
um real lopez for white and i don't know
or lopez for both white and black and
queen's gambit maybe declined or
accepted for both white and black
that those are like beginner friendly
even though they have a vast amount of
theory in them
it is still one of the
most commonly used openings by beginner
level players so
well i don't think i don't think black
is ever afraid of white playing h4
because if white plays h4 but gets but
gets a passport like i wouldn't i
wouldn't i wouldn't say
h4 is is is anything to be to be able to
be worried about right there's
this is what black wants
in fact black wants to create something
to play for because
what they have right now is clearly not
enough
so i would if i were playing as black
here i would welcome
what white's choice to play h4
you think that's why he played h4 then
okay then probably maybe he is judged if
that's if this is a true reason for why
he played h4 then he might have
misjudged the position i i believe once
again i'm not
i'm not a specialist but
h4 is
is a move
but once again
i don't think this is something to be
afraid of
all right let's go back here see
anything happened anything new happen we
have move number 90 so at this point we
have 18 moves until
until the official draw
otherwise y rush of h4
that's a good point actually the engine
wasn't ancient did not mind white's move
h4 actually i double checked with the
engine here
and h4 is not
yeah the engine doesn't mind h4 and here
but here you see we have we we do have
the g4 breakthrough which is which is
more it's it's by far
way more efficient
than if we were to break through with g4
over here because if we do a g4 right
now it it involves
both pawns being traded but after h4 g4
this pawn remains untouched right so
this is a potential hook for black
pieces to take advantage of
okay at later stages
thanks for talking about h4 well yeah i
mean at this point there isn't much
happening so i have to thanks for asking
the question i i have to find something
to be talking about and i can't because
well
you guys can see what's what's happening
yourselves
a bunch of shuffling
you know
there's no real plan
it's it happens sometimes it sucks that
um you know
you know this this kind of position
happened but it's part of the game
both players are doing their very best
i'm sure of it
this isn't a great game to have the last
one to be welcome to the commentary
booth
thanks this is my
second time being in the commentary
booth i guess
she talia got all the fun action herself
i mean i don't mind this you know it's
there is there's a charm in looking at
at this position you know
the charm being
is that i've i have some experience
winning positions like this
i from from the side that's trying to
make progress at this i i have um
um
i have a very similar looking game where
it was just it just everything like
everything was so locked down and i just
i just had this one plan right one plan
and i had to make it work to to break
through
and it wasn't working it was it wasn't
working until the end but what i did is
i shuffled pieces around
i made like 40 moves and i made a pawn
move and then made another 40 moves my
opponent eventually cracked under
pressure they they got under time
pressure they they panicked and they
they made it they helped me it worked
so maybe that's maybe that's the kind of
um
the kind of strategy aaron is going for
trying to
tire his opponent
i guess queen f4
might be an overkill but not really i
mean it's
did it happen i feel like no it did not
happen
it's not happened yet but maybe it will
happen well queen of placing a queen on
a four is a little bit scary right the
queen
doesn't have anywhere to run in case of
denture plus i'm not even sure if white
okay maybe white should not trade but
why not honestly why wouldn't why trade
right
now in fact without queens maybe if
white just brings the king over to e3
that should that should also do it
take energy forward to keep me here for
another 50 moves
yeah let me let me give aaron a call
real quick i'm like aaron aaron just go
ahead and take on g4 man i
i need i need the screen time
you find this position very interesting
yeah black got black pretty much got
everything they wanted yeah
in fact i i've i've uh i've
given a quick glance at the beginning
position and actually white was white
was a in a driver's seat in the very
beginning like somewhere here
right the positions like these engine
kind of believes that black black's
attack is not very likely to succeed on
the king's side and gives white
preference
but white played it a little bit
passively right black white decide i
think white just had this this this uh
um inner decision to um
to
to hold you know what white's game
strategy was to hold it seems and that's
why they made it
a conscious choice right this is a
conscious choice that that engine hates
because it kills any and all chances for
white right white
is weaker on the king side it's clear
that white is lacking space in the
king's side the general rule of thumb is
that you do not play on the side where
you're the weakest but you do play on
the sides where you're the strongest so
at least
try it right at least try something but
you know
this kills it this kills it and it
basically shows wise intention of of
holding
and um
well
it was oh it was good and all but it
maybe it's just maybe it's just some
kind of perfect game where both sides
both sides did everything they could and
it you know sometimes it happens it can
happen this way you're just playing
basically like close to perfect chess
like nothing happens you don't you don't
make mistakes your opponent doesn't make
mistakes
the only mistake white made in this game
is is their
their approach right so that's not even
a mistake it was rather inaccuracy which
kills white's chance to win but it's
still not enough to to claims white's
about why it's going to lose the game
they haven't made any critical mistakes
that would that would cause them to lose
am i blaming her i'm not blaming anyone
i i by no means
i by no means i'm in position to blame
anybody
i was just i was just saying that
typically
you don't
you this
in my mind this is a horror okay so what
white is going through this is a horror
in chess come true
because
it's
hopeless you either draw
or you lose because you eventually you
like miss misstep
and and go wrong somewhere
okay
so in my eyes this is
not fun i i don't enjoy
once again this is my personal
experience my personal
belief my personal preference it has
nothing to do with
anyone else it's me
i
don't like this
and
in my mind it also makes sense so in my
mind what i'm saying is also it also
follows a logical
sequence because
you i mean i want to win i'm i suppose
most people also want to win but when
you play a4
it's as if you're saying that okay i
give up i don't win anymore right so
you're you're giving up on
on your own winning chances
might have been the least of the evils
well
let's go back over there let's go back
to where a4 happened
no but you see but
but why did white even have to play a4
wouldn't it be just better to not do
that and in case in case black over
extends you see this is why i'm not even
sure if a4 is is necessary like
a4 is not needed because black is not
but first of all black is not trying to
break through there okay oh well we have
uh we have a guest uh the same guests
before no not as before same guests two
days ago right again two days ago okay
joshua please join us yeah absolutely
i'm absolutely free i'm looking at this
last final game between aaron and alex
and it seems that not much is happening
so i'm locked up i'm i'm kind of yeah in
fact alice alice has refused an exchange
a couple of times and i pointed out that
she only needs nine more moves to claim
a 50 move draw at this point yeah oh my
goodness yeah you're on move 90 98 yeah
yeah so she only needs nine to make nine
more moves and she can claim the draw
can you imagine i don't think i don't
remember this happened like ever in my
in my playing with this many pieces yeah
exactly exactly yeah exactly have you
have you seen any way that aaron could
try to break through well i've been i've
been trying to make uh sacrifices on e4
work but it doesn't seem to work at all
in fact there was a moment for where
aaron could have uh could have um
could have gotten this end game where he
would have to sacrifice an exchange on
f3
this is the
uh this
oh yeah joshua needs to to get hooked up
on the mic uh-huh i see yeah okay you
can hold it or just
i guess for now just hold it okay sure
thing yeah
so this is the spot where
quintex f3 and then
rook takes f2 could have happened and i
i yeah so i i've been telling people
that in my mind playing this position
would would give me more practical
chances to win than playing the locked
up position they're playing right now
because oh absolutely there is something
black can do at least there black can
reposition their pieces like so
not like like that but yeah so then
maybe eventually play g4 you know open
up open up the h file push the pawn yeah
if they if they
deem that g4 plan is not working they
can just do nothing and it's going to be
you're going for two results but yeah
and there is a breakthrough at least
exactly at this point there's a
breakthrough and yeah the rooks are not
as useful as you know as they would be
in open open you know position scenarios
okay so let's take a look at your game
though
we have um i'm in the iron section yeah
there we go
yeah there you go okay so you actually
had a very nice spin congratulations
yeah thank you uh
yeah i was um i was looking at through
your rook end game and started black has
some chances to to draw but apparently
it was not enough and you you've shown a
very very nice technique there but let's
get there first okay okay i have not
seen any of the games in any any part of
the game until until the end game
so everything is completely new for me
so you're playing
you're transposing into the queen's
gambit structure
into 12
yep this specific and e3 variation okay
yeah but it's called quiet variation you
know mozart's love defense quite
variation i didn't know that
uh e6 okay so i guess it's it's an
attempt to transpose the main lines and
you're playing it with name bd2 i
suppose
the idea behind knight bd2 is to develop
the bishop over to b2 and eventually
breaks through with e4 sometimes yeah um
it's also just to defend the c4 pawn
with the knight so you know of course in
a lot of the [ __ ] lines when you go
bishop d3 they'll take on c4 and make
you spend a second tempo with your
bishop and i would much rather spend a
second tempo with my with my knight okay
right all right so what joshua is saying
is that in this is this main variation
of maran
white bishop is forced to move twice
because it has to recapture the pawn on
c4 and gives black an extra tempo to
develop their pieces so with not on d2
white doesn't have to do that white can
just keep the bishop where where it is
uh let's see okay so actually ezra
played c5 immediately which is a an
interesting reaction to your to your
development
yeah i'm aware of this move but i've
never faced it before
and i was a bit foggy on the uh on the
theory
i was already basically out of book here
i'm already out of book yeah don't worry
about it
okay
c65
and bishop b5 check okay um
this somewhat reminds me of
of this of this english
english opening variation um the one i'm
talking about is
over here if we just
cheat and go to the very very beginning
and this is the variation i'm talking
about here
i'm just i'm just getting a similar one
so here but should be five now it's just
the same position but your zone is on d2
um
eventually black will likely have to
play with an isolated pawn because you
will take c5 and you know the difference
i guess is i'm up at tempo but also my
knight's on d2 instead of c3 it might
might be a little bit of a worse version
right okay
oh yeah okay wait you're right wait no i
think the tempo is more important than
having that on cc i think so yeah yeah
hard to know um i was surprised by
knight c6 because to my the best of my
memory the move was bishop d7 and um and
okay apparently that's correct
uh and then yeah you know just try to
trade a pair of pieces and then give
black the iqp uh-huh and you have you
know a comfortable advantage yeah
exactly so yeah i'm i'm basically in
love with these kinds of positions
because given the blood doesn't have any
any play against against your king and
the king's side then you can just
comfortably place one of your white
pieces on d4 block the the iso at the
pawn and slowly yeah slowly try to to
squeeze in the wind
but
yeah it didn't happen i suppose
knight c6 and he played it very quickly
so i was thinking he was uh he was still
in his like uh
theory right still in book um
and i thought for a long time played 95
which i guess is not correct but oh it's
not a very bad move yeah
if anything it makes perfect sense right
you're playing as much pressure as you
possibly can against the pen piece right
right okay so let's see bishop d7 is not
a move i was surprised by your response
because here apparently including queen
c7 is important i'm not sure why
it will be it is so
that's interesting and then take back
with the knight and then yeah that makes
sense there could be some tempo against
my queen i think i think the idea here
is to actually play c4 and use the poor
position of white queen yeah to apply
pressure and then maybe a6 is coming too
so i take on c5 now but then knight
takes yeah exactly yeah so now black
wins the tempo and maybe this kind this
version of our isolated pawn is not as
bad as the previous one right right
yeah
so bishop d7 happened and then you
happily just traded
played knight f3 yeah this this seems
like a very nice position where you are
about to be playing with a go against
the isolated pawn and that's exactly
what happened
yeah i i'm i'm loving this i this is
this is the dream of
okay it's my dream
probably is the dream of most chess
players because
not only is black not having any contra
on the kings side you also have a
perfect piece formation you have a
bishop here in an open position you have
a weakness to play against right so
bishop is coming to be too
a very very simple development to follow
okay so let's see
bishop takes c6 interesting choice
uh-huh yeah this i thought was an
important moment um my original plan
without really like evaluating or
calculating was just to stick a knight
on d4
but the more i thought about it i
thought black would just like trade
and trade and i realized that this is
and take the c file right this is not
actually good black has uh good control
of the dark squares they could even
bring the queen into a3
and um yeah well maybe not right away
here if it hangs oh yeah
but
at some point you're definitely the
weakness the weakness of the a3 squirrel
is likely to play a role and yeah you
would we would much rather have their
bishop and be do it in this case yeah
right the light square bishop isn't very
useful right so
okay so yeah i decided to take uh and
make him choose between the hanging pawn
structure or putting his queen on the
open file and running into rook c1 and
b4 being a threat um he went with the
hanging pawns and rook c1 xc8 knight d4
f5 well very aggressive was it was a
blunder it seems that it's
i guess it does seem like a mistake i i
was kind of expecting it because my
threat was knight f5 right so he's got
to do something to stop it i thought he
would either play f5 or or uh queen d7
or maybe g6 um isn't it 27 wrong is it
isn't quite oh it's not yeah it's not
anything oh actually it is the best way
of playing anyway
yeah i saw this position i thought i'd
be very happy
um so i actually i was kind of expecting
f5 actually um now
um
i i was calculating after f5 um okay
i
originally i thought f3 was just
crushing right
now knight g5
the original plan was h4 here uh-huh and
knight e6 rook takes c5 oh very nice but
but there's queen six right knight takes
e6
such a nice
trick yeah
so
you know and so i saw that rook takes c5
trick idea and i decided why don't i
just do it right away without weakening
my king side that makes perfect sense
because now so the the key here is to
understand that knight knight captures
on c5 is gonna is gonna lose because
there is no way out of this pen and
white will just simply follow with queen
c2 captures the knight and yes white
does have only two pieces for the rook
but in the middle game it's a major
advantage and if we were looking at the
end game it would be probably unclear
but in the middle game it's probably
just game over at this point yeah
okay let's go back so yeah so he takes
with the queen and i don't win anything
but i get to simplify the position i get
to trade when i have the better
structure right which you're generally
happy to do yeah and actually i think
the point in game is opponent game is
likely to be just winning for you right
because of hanging pawns right so that's
that's why you don't mind trades at all
right so queen c2 applying pressure
against c6
queen e6 rook c1 once again now black is
probably have to make a choice whether
they push with the push c5 or gold rock
c8 i suppose c5 just fails to f3 right
yeah and and the pawn is the opponent is
gone right so i couldn't have done that
just ruxia is the only move here bishop
d4
once again a very very nice technique by
joshua because here he is controlling
like all of the key squares he's making
a good use of his of his pieces right
the bishop the bishop is the key pieces
it's on a diagonal and helping joshua
take control over the c5 square so very
nicely done rook c7
now the engine lacks the move f3 a lot i
suppose just to follow through with the
idea of 4k taking full control over the
dark squares i see yeah
actually i'm i've been i've been kind of
is this working
no okay okay i was asking for too much
right never mind i just uh yeah i wanted
to i wanted to see if we can just yeah
uh
go back to b2 or
something a4 you go back to d4 yeah and
there's actually no way for black to to
get rid of all of those white pieces
there and are squares which is kind of
nice that would have been a good
approach and maybe maybe even four was
b4 b5 at some point yeah as long as i
didn't want to let him get a knight in
the c4 that's a good point so maybe not
maybe not before maybe it's too
premature maybe we need to get rid of
the knight from d6 first okay yeah this
would have been a better approach i was
just always so hesitant to play f3
whatever it does create a weakness right
so if anything goes wrong your opponent
has something to play against and i i
definitely understand where you're
coming from not wanting to create any
kind of counter play where you know
you're you're much better yeah exactly
yeah
okay so c5
this allows him to get his pawns rolling
a bit oh okay
for some reason it works c6 was a better
choice i'm not sure why oh interesting
there's quit you you still have queen c2
net f6
b4 okay this okay no no before never
mind
this is a draw
this is a draw uh something crazy
perpetual yeah crazy it's just a counter
player
black getting getting their pawns rushed
all right
okay so yeah this this was probably a
you know
an interesting approach but
would have been an interesting approach
but black to complicate the position
because here once again yeah there are
ways to go wrong you have to find ph
yeah it's not that simple and obviously
i i wouldn't i wouldn't really
understand
what what's the difference i guess it's
stopping that from coming out
now that the d3
yeah you want a tempo and then i guess
somehow you're going to win oh you're
going to pick up the pawns because and
then the d-bonds yeah exactly okay wow
yeah rook c6 that's not a you think uh
you don't think about moves like that
normally yeah definitely yeah
okay so c4 is
you know way more normal so it takes
takes and yes the c4 pawn has become a
little bit of a
of a
no it's not a it's not a burden for i
would say it's a burden for why to deal
with right but at least you can are you
winning material before i i thought i
was winning a pawn here yeah and he
seems like you are yeah you did win the
pawn so but this yeah this in game
becomes very technical now because you
have to be careful to not over over
trade and go into rook and four pawns
versus rook and three right
if it's all on the same side then i
think black draws here right if it's
knight versus bishop they draw if it's
rook against rook they draw exactly yeah
yeah so no yeah not too over not over
trade is is the key here i feel like i
can trade pieces but not the a and c
points i want to keep puns on both sides
right right and here actually the engine
doesn't even want to trade to trade
queens for some reason i would i
wouldn't mind the queen trade honestly
yeah so um i'm not interested i'm not
sure apparently queen b6 and keeping the
queens on the board is is preferred i
guess because you can use your queen
offensively but but then i mean yeah i i
was just i was not sure about this okay
um so it's just work it just works out
somehow somehow it just all falls into
place
that's okay it's yeah you can't really
see i would say you can't really see it
you kind of have to feel it's gonna be
like this and you know trading the
queens was also just kind of risk
mitigation because i was getting a
little low on time and i thought you
know exactly so yeah that's yeah your
decision to to simplify is completely
understandable because once again if you
if you keep queens on the board and then
you get low long time and you you're
running a risk into like wandering and
you don't want that right
and uh we have a result we do have a
draw was it the dro what's the draw
claim now that is the question was the
draw claimed by 50 movies let me see it
was claimed by 50 move role oh my god
ladies and gentlemen we have history
never have i ever seen a 50 move rule by
move 108 with all but one pair of light
and one pair of pawns on the board
that's crazy
all right wow very well done by alice
and aaron
good stuff aaron did have some chances
to win but unfortunately couldn't
capitalize on them and
let's go back to joshua's game oh no we
have to now we have to go all the way
back
spoilers spoiler alerts yeah
okay so here
queen trade happened bishop d4
g6
apparently it was not necessary i guess
but could have immediately tried to
to try and trade as much as possible
maybe not even knight b5 oh actually can
you even physically prevent trades maybe
this is why the engine doesn't like it
so much yeah bishop e5 and he's like the
try and then oh and then c3 yeah yeah
and then it's going to be rick and
foreign
three inevitably
oh okay you can't even take okay that's
true
no you can't you can't because i walk
the king over yeah you can yeah no no
you're just walking you know you just
were oh yeah you walked the pawn yeah
wait really
what is going on here oh okay i guess
okay this is not this is not clear i
don't know what's up okay okay never
mind but yeah this um
yeah okay i'm not winning this
no well maybe maybe but you you would
much rather try in some some different
way i'm pretty sure yeah uh okay so i
guess yeah i guess maybe this is why
trading queens was not such a good idea
because of an immediate immediate
counter play by black fortunately g6
happened that allowed a4 and 95 is no
longer the case so
i think at this point joshua was more or
less
more or less
good to go
uh okay
g4 okay g4
that was a mistake i was proud of that
move yeah i i would be proud of that
move too it's you see here you're
playing you're you're playing for
restriction you're restricting the black
knight as much as possible making sure
it's not it can't be used to once again
trade
in an unpleasant manner for white
but
apparently there is some so what
happened yeah recreator okay one so
what's happening here
okay i did see this i i was expecting
knight b7 um and then i king d2 rook d8
i feel like the king director
the king cannot approach the pawn
because there is room d3 it was a double
attack okay exactly
so yeah knight v7 i i'm not sure how to
how to make progress i was thinking
about f4 like i could try to push on the
other side not too far but uh yeah now
that i have to trade no no but this is a
very similar looking rook and game to
what you had in the game isn't it i mean
it's not it's not worse
it's worse because black black pieces
are bucking is more active in particular
right actually wow it's so active it's
already there yes yes this is the type
of position where i get scared i might
lose somehow because
yeah the king is the king and the poem
right again
under normal circumstances the king and
the pawn is enough to promote and the
rook itself cannot stop them so at this
point if even if white tries to stop
black from promoting but always have but
always has some checks on the side here
yeah to support the pawn i would
probably have to go rook a5 and then
start giving checks
yeah yeah to stop the promotion okay
all right so here fortunately uh for
joshua ezra did not recognize the
possibility and uh
there we had a uh this very nice
intermediate move by the way rook a5 um
yeah thank you amazing amazing technique
if king takes e3 obviously this would
wow
i mean amazing the only move that
doesn't lose the game uh well because
now black is just gonna promote so very
very important to make sure the king is
cut off on the sixth rank here before
recapturing the knight and i think this
i honestly think this in game is just
completely winning for white i wasn't
totally sure um instead of g5 king a7 i
thought was a good try okay so let's say
well first of all there's rook c1
okay no no so what i mean is is i think
these end games are just winning so
these types of end games are winning
because the king is completely cut off
and you can just play with king of four
yeah instead that's winning but king d3
rook f8
uh-huh ah not that simple huh okay so
key four here
can d4
you're going to have to get here
yeah now takes and and here
h3
and it's not winning
it's not winning wow
okay oh and now it is h6 h6 and then uh
wow and then and then just
g5 weight yeah just keep going
oh my god shuffle the rook
that is one of the most insane drawing
the drawing patterns have ever seen well
yeah i mean you don't you don't think of
this pattern when you look at the rock
end game you always think about checks
active defenses cutting off the king but
just shuffling the rug back and forth
wow insane
so okay you're correct yeah this is
actually not that simple i thought that
it's just completely winning i guess
after g5 it was
uh
well even after g5 there was a point
where i was worried he would have a draw
okay uh so king a7 makes sense uh rook
a5 king c2 oh yeah
um
is that here okay
well then you have rook five no actually
this was all this was all expected yeah
so h6 rook a3 here rook f8 he went rook
e8 i thought rook cafe would have been a
a much better try it might be winning
but i wasn't totally sure yeah so once
again i think the same there's the same
applies so just this position is just
when you just keep the king yeah yeah
and then eventually go after the
probably this
okay
yeah and then you know and i think the
blocking is not going to have enough
time to uh
or maybe i could even just trade pawns
maybe even yeah i would get into a
lucina position yeah maybe even do that
trade one pawn and then just go rookie
three rookie five yes because they can
use g8 f4 yeah yeah exactly and that's
winning before so okay
so
well i don't have much time to consider
it because i don't know what this entire
time oh that's crazy yeah so well done
yeah really well here i thought roxy six
was a bit more precise but ricky's free
runs just obviously yeah the idea being
is that just you know you may you make
your king push way simpler and this rook
is ready to support you know from f6
yeah okay yeah i see i i thought i had
to go on a3 to defend both pawns i
missed that the f6 square exists right
it's okay i mean it's winning regardless
but yeah it just felt a bit but yeah
okay so here after the i start black and
actually withdrawal but fortunately
there's three yes yes there is without
this move it's not winning yes
yeah that's important um after h5 it's
actually kind of interesting if i take
on h5 i think it's not it's not winning
anymore
yeah it's not winning i think oh
because he takes back i was wondering
about g4 instead oh g4 oh how cool and i
was thinking
i would have to take it and i think the
two connected pass pawns are good enough
yeah it is gonna actually if if the king
was not here if the king was here i
think it would be a draw because there's
checks on the side in this position oh
can you imagine are there
the king be able to hide on h6 and then
block with the jeep on
oh wait you're right i'm stupid okay
okay never mind why why did anyone say
that yeah that's that's that's right
okay i thought yeah so the king's way
too far away right so
still winning i mean you you kind of
have to do it you have to do it anyway
right
yeah okay yeah
okay so but but i guess he just takes
back on h5 and then that yeah exactly
just yeah just takes back and then and
then eventually if buck ever gets to
trade the g pawn for the f pawn that's
obviously it's a very simple draw and
and here yeah i think this is just
maybe it's still going rook a2 only when
it moves of course
uh yeah i'm not sure why but um i guess
what's happening oh again your king goes
behind and then you go over k5 and you
win the g5 pawn okay let's see not very
easy but definitely would be definitely
would be a different kind of game
because you have no time to figure this
out and rookie 2 is not yeah not not the
first not the first move that comes to
my mind when i look at this your chest
is hard somebody says in the chat yes
chess is indeed hard but that's why i
like rook and games because of stuff
like this it's exciting it it requires
you to calculate a lot makes it it is
this is what makes the game exciting for
me
yeah
and well the end of the game was fairly
simple
yeah ezra tried creating a passport
didn't work out i i pointed out that you
can just push and then capture an h2
right and you know because distracted
yes that's true and then i do you know
how to win queen queen versus rook and
game so i pointed out that here white
doesn't have opponent g4
have you ever tried beating the computer
yeah the engine the stock fish uh i have
tried i i failed i don't know
exactly i am successful sometimes but
not consistently yeah yeah i haven't
even done it once i said i've tried like
over 10 times and i haven't haven't done
it it's probably about a third of the
time for me that i guess i could be at
the computer that's impressive but i
don't bother training it because against
a human it's like usually
it's much easier because people yeah
humans don't define us as as precisely
all right well thank you thank you so
much joshua for joining us today i wish
you good luck for the rest of your games
the three games right in total so you
just you're you're you're
i wish you to finish strong great thank
you yeah good luck
all right
oops oh yeah this microphone
okay ladies and gentlemen i guess that
is
going to be it for us we have completed
all of the games i believe there might
be some other event
later on today is there going to be
anything on the channel
[Music]
oh okay so yeah i'm getting
i'm getting uh i'm getting the info that
we need we still need to go over the
results over the final results of this
round so let's do that
here we have the results of the gm
section of the norm congress event
josiah
steermann beat joshua ruiz vladimir bell
was drew by the gopati david brodsky
david brodsky drew ivan shitko
christopher rapko beat kostya kawitsky
and even park
drew victor motivation
there we have it
ladies and gentlemen it's official
there's round seven round seven okay
sorry i am suction absolutely joshua
who's been our guest just now has had a
nice win against ezra chambers gabriella
antoine drew pedro rodriguez
begum taker general drew julian prolaco
alice lee held her ground against aaron
grobinski and jennifer you unfortunately
fell prey to matthias marek
and that said the round number seven
will start in about an hour so stay
tuned
follow the games
have
fun i will be back
maybe
[Laughter]
all right
thanks for joining everybody hope you
had a good time have a good rest of your
day
bye bye
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you